at nearly 1500 meters the ferret bag is
the highest point in the black forest 31
ski lifts and more than 50 kilometres of
well groomed slopes make it as skiers
paradise the Black Forest is Germany's
highest mountain range after the El send
the snow cover lasts longer here than
almost anywhere else especially on the
fetch back button Britain bags largest
and oldest winter sports area
the first skiers showed up on Feldberg
mountain in 1891 the first ski lift was
in the Black Forest
so the sport has deep roots in this
region both to the chief on the undies
alike you're among the winter sports
trends to a beer in recent years is snow
kiting all you need is an open stretch
of snow some wind and lots of courage
the open space can generally be found
atop the felt bags broad plateau
the more than 70 Peaks higher than a
thousand meters in the Black Forest make
for prime winter sports conditions here
the Black Forest boasts more than 60
cross-country ski trails totaling
upwards of 2,000 kilometers
and as a special treat for cross-country
fans some of the Black Forest trails are
linked to form two long-distance routes
the longest stretching over 100
kilometers we've linked the trails in
different areas there are different
difficulty levels and in recent years
the trails have all been certified
they've been checked in the Daphna for
cross-country skiing have you're a
foreign side another way to tour the
Black Forest in winter is by snowshoe
marked trails guide hikers safely
through the great white south if weather
stays cold winter sports fans can enjoy
the region's broad range of activities
until April
you